the concept of heroes and the concept of
powers and the concept of you know kind
of everyday people just like suddenly
finding out they have like this weird
genetic mutation that gives them special
abilities I think a reason why I was a
giant x-men fan growing up as a kid and
why I keep even to this day secretly
hoping that I'll have some kind of
genetic mutation that will allow me to
either fly or turn invisible or teleport
or read minds or whatever hey everybody
a bunch of you requested I do a video
for the Shazam casting in the Justice
League DC EU universe so we have our
black Adam and we have our Shazam now so
if you weren't sure or you couldn't tell
from the clip that I included at the
beginning of that Zachary Levi has been
cast as Billy Batson in the Shazam movie
now separately they have a Black Adam
spin-off movie that's gonna probably
tell his origin story we don't know
exactly what the Shazam movie is going
to be about but I have a couple of ideas
and it mostly has to do with the new 52
mythology because of some copyright
stuff that happened between Marvel
because of the whole Captain Marvel name
and the Marvel family but there is a new
round of the Justice League ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video just a couple days ago they
released a trailer for Justice League
where one of the gods from Wonder Woman
was shooting lightning at Steppenwolf
and people were like wait a minute is
that the wizard Shazam because it was a
big flashback scene from thousands of
years ago so just to be clear as of me
posting this video I have not seen the
movie yet but I am almost positive that
there is no shows am stuff happening in
the Justice League movie and if they did
include anything from that mythos
because they're trying to build the
universe out then it's really just an
easter egg level so I'm only expecting
Easter eggs for the wizard Shazam but
anytime you see lightning in the Justice
League trailer it's either natural
lightning or it's the flash of Speed
Force Lightning and he's leaving his
speed trails as he's running around so
like this really cool shot that looks
like it was inspired by
comic book with the lightning bolt
behind Batman that's just the flash
jumping down to earth from the flying
fox behind Batman but what's happening
next year is as they're getting ready to
shoot the Shazam movie which means that
they probably already have a finished
script or they're finishing it so you'll
actually start seeing behind the scenes
pictures of them filming where ever they
end up going to do that like you've seen
behind the scenes Aquaman stuff
happening because they just finished
that movie same thing will happen next
year for Shazam they haven't said
anything about black Adams presence in
that movie but because the rock is one
of the most busy actors in the world
right now I'm not sure when they're
expecting the Black Adam movie to come
out so there's a little bit of confusion
about where these characters are gonna
pop up how they're going to introduce
them but a lot of you heard the name
Zachary Levi and you're like okay so
he's Fandral in the Thor movies what's
happening now perhaps next time we
should stop with the big one I can't
really talk about what happens to his
character during Thor Ragnarok without
getting into spoilers but suffice to say
he is now a major DC character so he's
probably not going to be in any more
Marvel movies but the whole idea with
casting someone like Zachary Levi is
that you're casting an adult to play a
child somebody with the mind of a child
in the body of an adult so that just
screams Zachary Levi so he's perfect for
that but you know because Shazam looks
like this really hardcore Superman style
dude obviously he's gonna be spending a
lot of time in the gym until then they
literally made the announcement then one
of his trainers said just got out of a
four hour session with Zachary Levi so
remember what Chris Hemsworth looked
like before he became the Thor character
they've actually posted some of their
audition tapes for that this is pre Thor
Chris Hemsworth this is what he looks
like now I've got lots of muscles so
technically more brains so they
basically need this childlike actor to
play this huge Holt out dude that could
fight somebody like the rock or Superman
convincingly because I believe that
casting notices have gone out for the
other members of the Shazam family the
other kids so you have Mary Freddy
Freeman Eugene Pedro Darla tawny all
people from Geoff Johns new 52 Shazam
run
so if you're not familiar with the
characters or you haven't read him in a
long time I would recommend you stick to
the new 52 Shazam run because that was
sort of Geoff Johns retooling the
character and routing his origins much
more in magic in mythology so that's
probably what the movie is going to draw
from but obviously it's going to be an
original story that'll deal with his
origins that are usually very faithful
to that part of it but whatever the
action of the movie is going to be
however he's going to defeat the villain
if that's not black Adam I think it will
be black Adam but you never know is that
it'll sort of draw on the things that
have been going on in the DC EU well at
the same time being its own separate
movie so I know you're all wondering our
Justice League characters like Superman
Batman going to cross over into the
Shazam Black Adam movies so just talking
about this first Shazam movie I think if
there's going to be crossover it will
only be like a really third hand cameo
type situation remember in Suicide Squad
how they talked about what happened with
Superman how the world had been affected
by what had happened I think that's
probably how they'll treat the Justice
League characters maybe we'll get a full
blown cameo by someone like gal gadot
because her character is rooted in
mythology and magic or maybe Henry
Cavill because in the comics Billy
Batson is a Superman fanboy
so hopefully they'll find really cool
ways of working that into the movie so
even if you're not gonna have a lot of
Superman it would be really awesome to
see a younger version of Billy Batson
whoever they cast to play the child
version of the character running around
in a Superman t-shirt but obviously it's
going to be the wizard Shazam whoever
they cast to be that that will offer him
all of his guidance as he gets his
powers and then takes on Black Adam but
if you have been following the history
of this they actually cast the rock is
Black Adam a long time ago and
supposedly they were gonna do the Black
Adam movie first now it almost seems
like they might do Shazam first but I
think that they'll save the Black Adam
origin for the Black Adam movie so if he
does appear during the Shazam movie
he'll probably just come in like you saw
in the animated movie that I've been
including all the clips for in this if
you're not sure what this is it's
Superman Shazam the return of Black Adam
it was from back in 2010 so it was a
while ago but his sort of tells a
version of the new 52 origin story so
it's actually good to watch too if you
don't want to read the comic so you can
watch that
movie but what they could also do is
have billy batson try to defeat the
seven deadly sins and they could just
turn the seven deadly sins into
possessions of regular people so like
he's actually fighting people instead of
fighting ethereal ghosts flying around
so you have absolutely no idea what's
going on with the character where do his
powers come from what's the deal with
the lightning how is it that he's so
powerful that he can fight Superman so
he draws on the different powers of a
bunch of different gods from the Greek
pantheon so I know you're all wondering
if this has crossover with the Wonder
Woman movie because she is literally the
daughter of one of the Greek gods early
theory is is that yes they will
tangentially connect him to the Wonder
Woman mythos because of her Pantheon but
the different gods are the different
names of the acronym Shazam so shows iam
is the name that he calls out to
activate his powers it's his name but
it's also an acronym that stands for
Solomon Hercules Atlas Zeus Achilles and
mercury so as the different names of the
gods imply they each give him different
abilities the Black Adam character is
just a dark version of that there's
about five thousand years old he's just
like a previous experiment by the wizard
Shazam in creating a champion of Earth
who went super dark when his people were
slaughtered so his family gets killed
he turns evil and start using his powers
for bad so the wizard eventually ends up
creating Billy Batson to combat that but
what'll probably happen is you'll start
hearing more announcements about actors
that they cast will start getting an
idea for the story they might do but
what will happen is I have new Game of
Thrones new Walking Dead and there'll be
new Marvel and DC on Monday so
congratulations to cake head here the
latest giveaway winner please private
message me so I can get your contact
details you can click here for brand new
flash and brand new arrow crossover
footage and you can click here for brand
new Justice League footage thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight